hello in this video i explain to you
what a stable frequency is and how
you can easily create
it online and so we also had
a frequency table that gives an
overview of the distribution of a
variable, more precisely an absolute frequency
and the relative frequencies of
the  expression of a variable now
you are rightly asking yourself what are
expressions of a variable and what are
absolute and relative frequency
expressions of a variable are, for
example, male and female for the gender
or for the highest
educational qualification without a
compulsory school leaving certificate and university the
absolute frequency now said  how many of
the 40 people are male or female
or
how many of the person have the highest
educational qualification, university entrance qualification,
compulsory school or no qualification,
so absolute frequencies
are those values ​​that indicate how
often the respective category or
the expression of a variable  e occurs
e.g. university could occur ten
times i only have five times and so on and
so forth
relative frequencies, on the other hand, indicate
how often the respective expression occurs in
relation to all cases and
therefore they are usually given
as a percentage, for example what percentage of the
respondents  stated university as the highest
educational
qualification let’s take a look at this
example
here nine people were asked what
their favorite food is
is cake ice cream and did so the
person answered the end value place
and did here we now see the
absolute frequencies of
two of these new people answered places
we answered as and three
answered do
we can see the relative frequencies here on the
right cake have answered 22 percent
have answered 44 percent have
answered 33 percent we say you
have a catering company and offer
exactly  these three desserts a  n
you would now like to know how many of the
desserts you have to buy for the next event
, then you could of
course get a very rough estimate from here
, which of course has to
be examined much more closely,
only the topic of
missing values ​​is very important, it is important when
creating it  and the interpretation of
often as tables to pay attention to the missing
or invalid values
in survey research there are
mostly missing values ​​where no answer i
can't say or i don't know was
answered so that the statistics
do not fall due to missing values ​​for
is today in  the
percentage and the valid percentage
are given in the frequency table how do i calculate
the valid percentage now the absolute
frequency of a characteristic is divided by
the valid cases don’t worry
i’ll show you that in more detail with
an example let’s say we asked 30 people
what their  favorite car
brand is five people hab  en
answered continued seven people
answered I can't say and the
rest indicated the car brands now
we would like to calculate
what percentage entered on site
that is of course very easy for
this we simply take the five people
who indicated on site and share it
through the 30 people we
interviewed in total so 5 divided by 30 is
16.7 so that we can now calculate the valid percentage
we simply have to
omit the seven people who
stated I can’t say anything
so the calculation is as
follows we have the same as under  5
person down here we only have
23 people because the seven people
are missing who have ticked i can't say anything
accordingly we have five divided by 23
and we get 21.7 percent so the
valid percent are 21 7 conti
normal percent of 16.7  And now
I'll show you how you can
easily create a frequency table online
here  ur please go to tape
de click on the statistics calculator and
then
if you want to use your own data click on
teach table
i have a small example here
i will just copy it and copy it
in this table
here we see the students and what
whose favorite car brand is
we would now like to have a frequency table for the
car brand let's go to
descriptive statistics and
simply drink the car brand now we
already see the frequency table below
we can also select that
we would like to have the percentage and the valid
percentage and  now
we get the
frequency table for the car brand below very simply we
see
three people have ticked vw three people
have ticked skoda two
people bmw and two people opel and
one person daimler a value is
invalid which we can see here
so easily datatec can therefore one
create frequency table
you want to know what a kreu  ztab
is and how to create it
watch the video on the left
if you want to know how you can do
other analyzes with delta tab
just watch the video on
the right and see you
next time